-The last "SNL,"
the last live "SNL,"
was the Eddie Murphy show.
-Whoa.
-Which was fantastic.
What a joy to watch.
Was it an exciting week for you?
-I was freaked the hell out,
because he's just, like,
such a pillar of
"Saturday Night Live" history.
I was --
I was so jacked up.
-You had a sketch
that was cut for time
they put online,
called "Aidy Bizzo."
-Yeah.
-Where it was you and Lizzo.
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, yeah.
-Did you -- Was that --
Was that a fun thing to do
-Oh, my God.
It was a dream come true.
I mean, Lizzo came and was lik
spanking me at points.
[ Laughter ]
And we were gonna wear
different outfits,
and she was like,
"No, I want to match."
And I was like,
"Thank you, Lizzo."
[ Laughter ]
No, it was a dream come true
And we shot with Eddie,
which was so cool.
-Yeah, there was a scene
with Eddie
back in the wardrobe department.
-Yeah, and I will say, like,
I thought we would sort of
shoot anything where he wasn't
supposed to be there
without him,
but there was a point
where he was sort of, like
waiting to come in,
and we were just shooting.
And my line
was just to be, like,
"I can't believe Eddie Murphy'
hosting the show this week."
And feeling him, like, jus
nearby while I had to say it
I kept going,
"I can't believe Eddie Murra
is hosting the show!"
[ Laughter ]
"Tonight!"
And just pure panic.
And, of course, every time
he was like,
"It's Eddie Murphy!"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Yes, I know that!
I'm just scared."
[ Laughter ]
And it happened
probably three times.
-Wow.
-Which is actually too many.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And it did make me scared
that my brain was broken.
But then, I will say,
he was very cool about it.
Later, he came by and was like
"Oh, you're so funny."
And I was like, "That mean
a lot coming from Eddie Murray
Thank you so much."
-There you go.
Full circle.
-Yeah.
-You -- I want to ask,
there's a line in the song
and I believe you wrote
the Aidy Bizzo song
with Michael Che.
-Yes.
-"Smang" was a word
that I was not familiar with
-Yes.
Well, I would be happy
to tell you about smangin' it.
-Please.
-Yeah, it's basically --
It's sort of a combination o
to smash it or to bang it.
-Gotcha.
-It's to smang it.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And Lizzo really did tweet that
about Michael Che,
that she wanted to smang it.
And so,
Che and I wrote it together.
And as we were sitting
to write it, I was like,
"You gotta let me smang it."
[ Laughter ]
"You've got to let me talk about
smanging it."
And he sort of, like,
begrudgingly was like, "Fine."
But I feel like, by the en
of it, he got into it.
[ Laughter ]
-You also had
a fantastic sketch this year
with Harry Styles,
where he played your dog.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I know.
-It's a very, very funny sketch.
Also, very sweet.
And great payoff, I feel,
as though, it's a good lik
minute, 90 seconds
before the turn happens
in the sketch --
very patient
piece of sketch writing.
-Yes, I love to make
them wait for it.
-Yes. And in this case,
the waiting was the reveal
that Harry Styles
was gonna play your dog.
Was he an easy sell
or a hard sell
to play your dog in the sketch
-He got right on damn board.
-Yeah?
-Yes, I mean, Harry Styles..
-Yes. He seemed --
He seemed incredibly game
as a host,
which made for a great episode
-He was so game, and, like
right away, when he got to set
we were like,
"You need to get on all fours,
and I'm gonna dangle
this garbage in your mouth
[ Laughter ]
And he was, like, totally down
And then, like,
truly, the next scene,
we were like, "Put your head
in the garbage can,
pretend to be a dog
smelling garbage,
and put it in your mouth,"
and he was like, "Okay!"
[ Laughter ]
He is really, really great
-That's all you can ask fo
from an "SNL" host.
And now Adam Driver,
which I see --
third or fourth time --
he's an old hand at it now
And he must be great
to work with.
-He's a pro!
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's gonna be so fun.
-That's awesome.
-He goes hard.
And he's a true actor.
-He is really a true actor
-Yeah.
-And it's really fun to watch --
Not that you're
not all true actors,
but it is really fun when --
-Oh!
Do you think
you're a true actor?
-No!
[ Laughter ]
But that would be
the funny thing about --
And when you realize, like
there was times
where a host would show up
and you realize,
"Oh, they only know one way.
They don't have like,
"I have a Broadway style,
and I have
a sketch comedy style,"
They only know one thing.
-Totally.
Or, like,
I've had multiple times --
Like, once,
I was playing a chicken
who was in love
with Ryan Gosling.
And, like, at multiple points,
he was like,
"He really loves her,
and he wants to be with her.
-Yeah.
-"But he can't,
because she's a chicken,
and he's on the run."
And I was like, "Oh, you're,
like, thinking about this.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I, like, literally --
Like, to me, it was just like,
"Bawk bawk bawk!"
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"I've never thought twice
about a single thing I've done."
-Oh. Well, people --
There would be times
where someone say, like,
"Hey, the host has some
questions about this character,"
and I'd be like,
"Oh, all I know is
where they stand
and what they say."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-Like, I put no thought
into their past,
and I have no thoughts
about their future."
-Past?
-Yeah.
It's like, "What was this gu
doing last week?"
I'm like, "I don't bleep] know
There was a different host
last week.
-It definitely, like, reveal
how absolutely
simple-minded I am,
'cause I'm like,
"You want me to stand where?
Be loud?
You got it."
[ Laughter ]
-Boom!
Cash the check!
-And, hey, it's working out.
-It's working out.
Eight seasons!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aidy Bryant, everyone!